problem 12. the prime factorization of a
natural number that's just you can kind
of view that as positive integers
sometimes you'll throw zero in the
natural number definition depending on
what context you're working in but the
prime factorization of a natural number
n can be written as n is equal to p r
squared where p and r
are
distinct prime numbers fair enough how
many factors does n have including one
and itself well they're saying this that
this is some natural number that can be
written this way let's just pick one
example so if we just set p i'm just
going to pick some prime numbers here p
is equal to 2 and r is equal to 3
then n is equal to p
times r squared times 3 squared which is
equal to two times nine which is equal
to eighteen this is just one instance
one n that satisfies these conditions i
could have picked five and seven or i
could pick three and two but all of them
should have the same answer because
that's what this question is implying so
this is a possible n and then how many
factors does it have let's factor it out
it's got 1 and 18
and 9
and 6.
so it's got 1 2 3 4 5
6 factors so the answer is d and you
could try it out with other numbers if
you like make p is equal to make p equal
to 3 and make r equal to 2 then you'd
have 3 times 2 times 2 you'd have the
number 12 and you'd see its factors are
1 and 12
2 and 6 and 3 and 4. so you'll see the
same thing exactly six factors
problem 13
given p n is equal to 150 where p is a
prime number and n is a natural number
which of the following must be true
so let's just think about it what are
all the possible values for p to do that
we'd have to figure out the prime
factorization of 150. i'll do that in
black
so 150
let's do its prime factorization that's
2 times 75
75 is 3 times 25
25 is 5 times 5.
so 150
150 is equal to 2 times 3 times 5 times
5. that's its prime factorization
so p could be any of these numbers so
for example p could be
if p was 2
then
n would be 3 times 5 times five if p
were three
then n would be two times five times
five if p were five
then n would be two times three times
five right let me draw let me write this
make this a little bit clearer this
these are my p's
because p has to be one of the prime
factors of 150 and then n is whatever's
left over when you divide by that v
right and each of these cases so let's
look at the choices which of the
following must be true
p is a factor of either 10 or 15.
let's see 2 is a factor of 10
3 is a factor of 15
5 is a factor of both 10 or 15. so that
actually looks like the correct answer
let's write that let's square that right
now this could be other choices just to
make sure we haven't missed anything
10 is a factor of n
let's see over here well no 10 is not a
factor of this n 3 times
5 times 5 is 75 10 is not a factor of
this number so it's not going to this 10
is a factor of these two choices but
this is a possible n right here 75 could
be n so this is not the correct answer
n is a factor of either 10
or 15. n is a factor remember these are
our n's right here these are the
potential ends
this is not a factor of
need this is neither a factor of 10 nor
15 10 or 15 or smaller numbers than all
of these over here
and then so this is not the answer
and then 15 is a factor of n
15 is a factor of n so in order of 15 to
be a factor you have to have a 3 in
there and you look at this choice right
here 2 times 5 times 5 this is 50.
this n right here is 50. 15 is not a
factor of 50. so our first inclination
was correct p is a factor of either 10
or 15.
next problem
all right
the greatest common factor of n and 540
is 36
which of the following could be the
prime factorization
of n so let's just think about this a
little bit the greatest common factor of
n and 540. so the largest number that
goes into both
540 and this mystery number n
is 36 which of the following could be
the prime factorization of n
let's just take the prime factorization
of everything just so we can kind of go
down to the the most digestible parts so
the prime factorization of 540
let's see 2 times
what is it 270 this is the same thing as
3 times 90 and 90 is 3 times 30
and 30 is 3 times 10
10 is 2 times 5. so the prime
factorization of 540
is equal to there's two twos here so
it's equal to two squared times three to
the third
times three to the third
times five
that's 540's prime factorization
now the great the greatest common factor
of n and 540 is 36 36
is equal to what that's i'll do it right
here 36
is 2 times 18 that's 2 times 9 and that
is 3 times 3 so 36 is equal to 2 squared
times
3 squared
so n has to be some multiple of this
some multiple of this
that does not
that is that is not still go into 540.
let me show you what i mean let's see if
if i
which of these could be possible prime
factorizations of n
so a is 2 times 3 squared well that
doesn't work because remember n this
right here 36 has to be divisible into
into our n
36 or 2 squared times 3 squared is not
divisible into this because we don't
have a 2 squared here so a is not our
choice i'll do it in red when i knock
out choices so a is not our answer
2 squared times 3 squared this is
tempting because 36 definitely goes into
2 squared times 3 to the third sorry
this is 2 squared times 3 to the third
2 squared times 3 squared definitely
goes into that in fact it goes into it 3
times this is 36 times 3 right here
right because the difference between
this number and this number is the power
of three and this one has a higher power
of three so 36 definitely goes into this
number but we have to be very careful
this number
this number right here also goes into
540. if n
if n
was this number right here then n would
go into 540 because this is 2 squared
times 3 to the third 2 squared times 3
to the third
then the the greatest common factor of n
and 540 would be this
instead of this
so this can't be our answer because if
this was our n then n would be the
greatest common factor of n and 540. so
this can't be our choice because this is
actually a larger number that goes into
540 than this one right here let's look
at choice c
two to the fourth
times three squared times seven this
looks good because 36 definitely goes
into this number two squared definitely
goes into two to the fourth goes into it
four times three squared definitely goes
into three squared and then we're
multiplying it by seven and what's good
about this is we're multiplying it by a
number or a factor that's not in 540.
so this looks like our best choice right
here
this looks like our best choice let's
look at the last choice just to make
sure we haven't missed something
two to the fourth times three to the
fifth this part right here is definitely
a multiple of our greatest common factor
so it looks good so far but then we do
it times
five
times five if this was our n
if this right here was our n then the
greatest common factor of this number
and 540 would not be 36 it would be
let's see we would have 2 to the squared
because that's the largest power of 2
that goes into both of them it would be
2 squared times 3 to the third times
three to the third
right because that's the largest power
of three that goes into both times five
this would be the greatest common factor
of this number and 540 is this which
happens to be 540. so it can't be this
choice right here
and again using the same argument on
choice b the greatest common factor of
choice b and 540 is 2 squared
time because it 2 squared goes into both
numbers times 3 to the third
which is a very different number or not
a very different number it's 3 times 36
so that's the other rationale for why b
is not a legitimate answer
next problem 15
let me scroll down a little bit
a shipping container a shipping
container
measures eight feet by twelve feet by
twenty four feet let me draw that so we
have eight feet
by twelve feet
and then it's 24 feet just like that 24
feet so maybe look something like that
that's actually what shipping containers
really do look like
looks something like that
the containers to be filled with
identical cube shaped boxes each having
sides measuring a whole number of feet
which of the following expressions
represents the smallest number of such
identical boxes that could be packed
into the container with no empty space
remaining
so how
they say the smallest number of
identical boxes which means we will need
the biggest possible we need the biggest
possible boxes that can be fit cubic
boxes that can be fit into this
container with no space so the
dimensions of those boxes have to be the
greatest common factor of 8 12 and 24.
so we could write this right the
dimensions or let me see the box side
has to be equal to the greatest common
factor of 8 12
and 24. so what's the biggest number
that goes into 8 12 and 24 you could do
this from inspection it's four and you
can verify that if you if the boxes were
four on the side then in this dimension
you'd fit eight divided by two four of
them or two of them so you'd have one
two boxes in that dimension
in this dimension over here you would
have three of them
right 12 divided by four you'd have
three boxes in that dimension and in
that dimension
you would have let me draw these just
like that
you would have six one two three
four five one two three four five six
you would have six or 24 divided by four
so if you want to know the total number
of boxes you fit i'm just looking at the
choices they just they didn't actually
do the math they say well in this
dimension i have eight divided by four
boxes
in this
dimension i have 12 divided by four
boxes so times 12 divided by four and in
this dimension i have 24 divided by four
boxes
24 divided by four so that's how many
boxes we can fit we could multiply it
out but this is actually
one of our choices
right there so the whole key is just
realize well look i'm trying to pick the
if the boxes have to be cubes and
there's no remaining spaces the
dimension of the boxes has to be
divisible into all three of these all
three of these numbers and i want the
biggest possible dimension because we
want the smallest number of boxes and
that's where we got the greatest common
factor of four and then you say okay
four and if if we have boxes of
dimension four feet then in this
direction we're gonna be able to fit
eight divided by four this direction 12
divided by four and this direction 24
divided by 4.